[Musique]
la somme de 120 enfants
nous voilà merci beaucoup
vous avez des belles moustaches monsieur
to write dont le dit ou pas je ne
soutiens pas une bouche comme elles
veulent un bon j'ai pas le temps non
plus une moustache mais ses moustaches
sont pas une histoire
récemment des questions bien d'épineuses
une histoire oui d'une firme s'est
emparé de la photo on la vend en
publicité et puis récemment mois de
mois de mai dans le coin demande mais il
ya le bras femmes qui veulent se
plaignent que je lui avais pas livré son
chalet vais pas et je lui dis à ma
réponse lorsque j ai dit que je n'avais
pas de charbon qui me dit ah ça va vous
avez aimé faire la publicité que vous
occupez du charbon quel pas moi je me
suis dit tiens elle est folle c'est tout
et quelle cata rappeler quelques jours
la preuve d'une deuxième personne savait
un billet alors les charrons vous n'avez
plus besoin de lui citer maintenant nous
une caisse qu'elles ont il a fallu qu'il
ira vers une quatrième qui dit alors
fait de publicité pour la télévision
mais dit oui à la vue de votre photo
dans tout paris et en banlieue
j'ai proposé ici s'il fait plus qu est
ce que vous voyez quand vous étiez très
nombreux du champion je te dis le monde
et vous continuez je continue c'est un
métier qu'il vous plaît c'est un petit
de jeunes et vous avez pris le café
pourquoi parce que je suis le café
marché avec ça ne fait lever le camp
donc vous êtes vraiment ce qu'on fait à
bunia le brouillard vrai bulldog ben ali
il est bien beau et bien gentil vôtre
monsieur toure et mais à part ces
mirobolants moustache
qu'est-ce qu'il a tous que les 700
autres bunia de paris d'abord il est
sympathique et ensuite l'ambiance
campagnarde qu'il a su conserver dans ce
minuscule bistrot parisien lui a valu
des clients célèbres qui venait là pour
se détendre autour d'une bouteille de
beaujolais
maintenant quoi cette charnière a
certainement saliver des champions il
est l été on sent un peu plus tard cette
hernie mais l'hiver lasseter mais je
conçois la sueur du soir 6h30
suivant les jours suivants le froid
suivant suivant nous avons du
combustible pac c'est un récit d'une
passion début et ça change
[Musique]
m
à 10 heures il ya le casse-croûte non à
8h30 c4 puis depuis 7 heures depuis son
âme il relevé invité à monter quelques
ce stage a été très mal et david polly
8h30 c'est le casse cou de pied on a
faim et le bon casse cous c'est là que
vous allez vous baigner vers giuly le
moteur à à 30 ans reçoit le peugue
arrive sur votre route
d'ailleurs si j'avais un pouvoir
on a toujours une petite idée de quand
même d'avoir
il ya des boulevards est pas mauvais
cela la marque c'est très bon pour
l'oublier ça vous êtes un peu un ami dr
nom assez les artistes de l'artiste sur
tous leurs discours et les comédiens
aussi les jours cima j'ai eu beaucoup ce
que veut dire que j'aime beaucoup et que
justice et hubert deschamps qui vient
souvent de voir que j'aime beaucoup
non il ya beaucoup d'écrivains et parmi
les mets préférés je citerai entre le
blondin et j'ai le pnue qui a écrit
plusieurs volumes dans un livre intitulé
les germes ya une part sont présents
alors il ya sept ans trois volumes le
tout bien sûr les gens viennent pour le
second il a pu atteindre la plaie
constance et le troisième set que je me
suis repas commun qui serait le
troisième set et j'avais sa seule source
il a eu le plus de buzz tablette apple
choisit ici il ya une particularité que
c'est d'y aller tous les clients en
leurs verres gravés à leurs noms
c'est assez rare les anecdotes de
monsieur tout raid sont nombreuses
puisqu'il a vu défiler trois générations
d'écrivains un de ses premiers clients
fut un homme qui déchaînait les passions
il faut bien que nous ayons donné
lorsque j'étais jeune lisait on sur vos
relevés aux pertes
je vais 24 25 ans et il était client de
la maison auquel je travaillais alors
nous allions livrer musique15 à deux et
il est arrivé force plusieurs fois celui
qu'il a reçus et nous recevait une façon
forte et noir il nous avait tous venus
marquer cet homme là parce que il était
gentil comprendront pas les ondes c'est
un joueur qui nous sauve feu tout mon
coeur qu'est-ce que j'ai soigné tandis
que lui il verra bonjour messieurs les
champs joignez brise ces petits mots il
va ça nous touche beaucoup
il nous a posé de questions sortie que
ce jour là avait répondu un peu à lui
demande si je te dis parce que et il
s'avérait densité qui quitte à tiflet
quelqu'un à partie il le prenait à
partie quelques fois pour le mois temps
alors certains genres du quartier les
enfants nos clients n'ont pas tendre
d'israël même si on répète tout le temps
là nous savait mais en toute franchise
je voulais savoir ce que les lecteurs ne
dise de vous mais ils disent que quand
vous avez quelqu'un en particulier trop
longtemps ou a répété pendant un mois de
janvier 1 jenson qui venaient nous voir
temps en temps tue pas toujours comment
d abord il a vraiment la réputation oui
cette priorité pour le moment mais quel
est ce que je veux il est attaché gens d
ici le nom le voit plus depuis plusieurs
années on a paru il a été remplacé par
les jeux vitaly est un peu picolé un
père vidalies il était plus tu es plus
gai je te que tu es là quand il avait bu
un petit coup de trop alors il était
plutôt du bruit c'était la gaieté
c'était peut-être autre chose au losange
beaucoup avec l'ajax on lui parle
désormais d année de temps en temps mais
vrai souvent en groupe avec 2 8 ou 10 et
j'ai demandé un petit casse-croûte
l'affrontant ne vous écoutait avec fois
cela nous avions comme mon client
pour jenny et qu'il est souvent sur le
voir
combien déployer son départ il était
gentil comme tout dépend beaucoup de
temps que nous allions faire et savoir
genre l'exposition de peinture qui
consistait à encourager les jeunes et
débutants
il ya une quarante trois inscrits 40 il
ya eu 46 ans qui ont tenté leur toile et
il y avait un jury qui ont distribué les
plis et la fin il y avait des s'imposer
débutants qui était très très bien et
les parlementaires halal on est député
et comme moi pas d'ailleurs il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont avant tout les
déjà de nombreuses années mais ils ont
été rayées policières contre les taupes
et trompe jamais en lui volant nous ne
devons surtout pas de députés ici
quelques petites histoires lors de
l'actionnement les députés surtout pas
ce qu'est ce qui vous a conservé ses les
conversations beaux jours le beau
journée c'est pas la conversation il
faut boire du bon vin au niveau de la
meute aurez vous avez rencontré monsieur
toure est au pays
je vais renconter à l'envers où c'est
exactement dans le cantal près de saint
front parce que pour vous je crois ça
ferait le cantal s'élève à sa force a
plus vraiment le merde parce qu'internet
saint flour les deux fois aux vernets à
sa ville qui est saint flour qu'ils
m'ont dit de saint flour et louvain je
suis la fille de monsieur touré trouve
une des filles et c'est vous qui allez
reprendre
l'exploitation je pense que je vais
maintenir le bistrot de papa oui vous
avez un autre métier
j'ai aussi à mes moments perdus à notre
métier je chante je chante des choses
sud-américaine qui
[Musique]
le syli
vous chantez des vieilles chansons
françaises aussi ou non je connais pas
pas tellement
je ferai le répertoire de monthermé
temps en temps les chansons qui ne suis
pas de la guerre de 14 quand c'est la
statue de kléber détruit un truc
extraordinaire
je ne vois plus passer de patrouille
française et je ne vois plus dans l'ère
flotter les trois couleurs
je n'entends plus chanter label
marseillais je n'entends plus de nos
clairon vainqueur la sofres alentours
c'est très long c'est ton de chansons
caire je pensais que si couple est
excusé jamais eu envie d'écrire
je n'ai jamais le temps je vous les
aimez écrire quoi comme poule et qu'il
faudra voir en eux le goût et j'ai
beaucoup à apprendre et je mais je n'ai
jamais le temps je vais jamais pensé une
seule fois et cueillir y viendrez vous a
jamais eu envie de faire autre chose je
suis consacré à mon commerce de mes
enfants et ma foi tout va pour le mieux
du monde doit y m'a redonné du feu quand
les croquants peser les croquants
[Musique]